all right Hazel yes Hazel where'd you
grow up where are you from originally oh
I'm from Vegas
from Vegas
tell me about your family growing up
um
I was a doctor when I was a kid
and I was abused
so I didn't have a good life
where were you biological parents do you
know yeah my mom she passed away last
year or two years ago but why did you
why did you not stay with your I don't
know yeah
how was your family with the adopted
parents
not good
how far did you go to school
11th
11th grade
do you remember what kind of kid you
were when you were in high school
I was quiet
yeah
do you have friends back then
hey siblings yeah
I got two sisters
only one
you have any good memories of your
childhood
no
[Music]
are you sure you're comfortable talking
about all this stuff yeah
okay
you started working
as a prostitute at what age
16 16.
how did you first get started you
remember
those aren't running away
from childhaven in Vegas
I'm sorry I end up running away from my
Firestone
and I met a guy that
introduced me into it
how do you know
24 24.
where did you move to L.A
as I got tired of Vegas
I got tired of being picked on
but I still get picked
for drugs a part of your life
yeah
you work Figaro Street now
you do it with you have a pen third yeah
I'm not doing that myself
the smarter way to go
huh it's a smarter way to go about it
yeah
yeah I like to do it by myself because I
don't want to get hurt
I'm sorry I said I'd do it by myself
because I don't want to get hurt you
know
um
yeah I got two I got two kids
where are they right now
family
you see your kids
sometimes
how does this
life that you're living affect you
emotionally do you get depressed
sometimes
[Music]
what's the hardest part of this
um the hardest part of this is
the fact that
people make fun of me every day
about who I am and what I do
we shame you about being a prostitute
it's not it's not it's not that
you know they don't even know I mean
they know but it's like it's not that
it's
I guess because females don't like me so
they always talk crap about me
not always being mean to me
I want to kill myself three times
because of females
you try to kill yourself three times
how'd you do that
um by showing up 100 cc of um
some math
do you have any friends
no
where do you stay do you have a room to
sleep in
do you have any family that you can go
to whatever when I got a sister but
it's not it's not healthy over there
what do you worry about now what are you
afraid of
what do I worry about
I mean
really nothing
are you coming I left you must get to me
you know
but it's like
they really know who I am they know how
to piss me off I'm sorry I said because
they really know who I am like they know
I had to piss me off because because if
they piss me off
I smashed their head into this man you
know
I'm kind of crazy
that's another reason why they don't
like me
I mean they talk a lot of crap but they
won't frighten me
you know
tell me about your your customers The
Men Who pick you up
I don't basically just have regulars I
mean
I lost my phone
because
if you must like to still find
do you have regular clients
you lose your phone and you kind of lose
contact with them yeah
I have to rebuild your
yeah quiet face all over again
so if you if you had to live your life
all over again what would you have done
differently
um
[Music]
finished high school
and went to college and got my degree in
nursing
you want to be a nurse
you're dressed like a nurse today
I know is that a coincidence
you've chosen a tough lifestyle to
Survivor yeah you have things happen to
you that
um I've been shot two times um
I've been stabbed once
these are my tricks or by fence
I was stabbed once by a female
I've been shot twice by two different
things
what do you do for fun
um
I like to hang out
you really Casitas yeah
I mean
yeah I mean no I don't give up I'll just
sit there
you know because every time I can't
believe you know I never win
you know cause I'm not good at it so I
just sit there you know
and they ask me you know just have fun
is there anything you do that makes you
happy
is there anything I do that makes me
happy
yeah there's a lot of things that I do
that do make me happy like what I'm
going to because he thought he's not
just being myself rather females talk
about me or not you know
just sometimes I let them get underneath
my skin I will not do that let's make
sure that they win you know
you have goals and what you like to do
with your life yeah my goal is to
you know get back you know get my life
back on track you know uh get my GED go
to college get my
big and my CNA license get my
RN license then
you know we'll keep them moving forward
from there
because I mean I love kids you know I
like working with kids
that'd be great
do you feel like you were ever loved as
a kid
um yeah and no
reason why I say that is because
my sisters they loved me but my adopted
mom she didn't
so
yeah
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret was
making going down the wrong path for
making the wrong decisions in life
like that was because of the friends you
had or
is it just your bad decision making I
both
being around being around the wrong
people
and make it you know just listening to
the advice
do you have any good Role Models when
you were a kid yeah I did
you find yourself sabotaged sometimes
sometimes I love people just manipulate
me and they get to me and
I think you're down the wrong path yeah
so what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um 24 years
the most important lesson I learned is
I don't know it's just like basically no
matter what you do or no matter how much
you know people talk [ __ ] about you just
you know
keep going because if you don't then
you just can't fall
all right Hazel thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you
I hope you find a better path for
yourself
thank you very much